in previous videos you could see us
renovating our sketchy ruin
now that we have a roof it's dry inside
so we can start working there and get
closer to having a nice refuge for the
winter season
we will keep using natural and reuse
materials as much as we can
it's always a challenge but let's see
how it goes welcome to a new project
Camp update
to make our little ruin into a really
nice house we're going to do some work
on the interior let me show you how we
are going to do this
inside the big wooden construction that
we already have placed we are going to
place a stick frame we're going to place
them a little bit under 50 centimeters
so we have to squeeze in the cork this
makes for a more better insulation and
then in this Tech frame we can place our
windows and doors
after that we can put the cork into our
stick frame
and then finally finished with a wooden
boards
okay this is our plan I'm gonna continue
working on a 3D model for a bit and
Frank is going to start to work inside
the first step is to paint the beams
that we sit on the ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're now about to put in the
interior framing after that we put some
insulation panels
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the window frames are going to be
mounted inside the wall frames and to
have a
nice finish for the interior of the
window frame we are making kind of a box
around it
[Music]
that's one I think so
nice let's meet a little bit of covering
I believe it's still a bit too long yeah
but we cut that out huh we have decided
to put the screws in from the inside of
the window frame they will be a bit more
visible
but we can always take the windows out
when that's needed
yep yep
there you go
okay yeah yeah that's it
okay
all the wall framing is in place now
it's ready to be corked with the
insulation
and the windows are also in place
this ruin is going to be a guest house
soon and also a house where the core
team can be in winter
and they want a little bit of luxury so
it's going to be a bathroom
Frank how are we going to make a
bathroom yeah so we already laid out the
bottom beams
we're going to have a toilet on that
side we're going to have a shower on
that side of course a door in between
and our first step now will be to put up
the wood frame
foreign
[Music]
foreign
is in place but before we put in the
cork we're gonna put electric pipes in
the walls
we're gonna have sockets in the corners
of the rooms we're gonna have some power
in the kitchen which is going to be on
that wall and in the back wall of the
ruin
towels there's going to be our fuse box
and the place where all the piping comes
in
it's coming
and go
[Music]
oops
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to have a kitchen here where
I'm sitting and from here the water is
running down towards
the shower I'm going to Mark now where
the pipe is going to run and then we cut
it out in the back and later the cork
will be in front of the pipe
[Music]
yep
it's corking day big step and I'm happy
to get into it we're gonna put the cork
panels in between the frames
we made them uh a little bit snug fit
so I'm gonna have to tap it in I guess
and then we have a gonna have a warm
house after today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Mr T how you doing all right have a go
at this
bloody fits mate a few little gaps left
over because
they have a bit of a weird measurement
and we wait for leftovers that fit here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's putting finished her up but he
didn't film it didn't film it but
there's this
this bit up here
which is a little bit less satisfying
is it in bang on mate bang on
all the cork
finished inside insulation is done
we the next step inside would be to
Mount the the boards that will cover the
walls
but they come from The Sawmill and they
didn't arrive yet so in the meantime we
are going to continue finishing the
outside we still have to put Granite
around this door frame
so that's what we're going to do now
foreign
I think there should be a quick process
just take the grinder
down the back
doesn't have to be deep just to make a
bit more okay surface to attach cool
okay then I'll start with that
[Applause]
I found the blade of the grinder it's
wearing out pretty fast cutting this
granite
I'm gonna try uh with this uh cooling
installation
to uh have a bit of a longer grind
with this we also have more of a
mechanical connection that the cement
goes into these grooves
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
's making some more room
oh
foreign
bang on mate
yeah yeah say it say it
bang on mate no no no no no just like
yeah what would what we're gonna do now
you know
Batman is filling up uh
space between the bricks and the granite
foreign
water
and pure cement
to make it stick better
[Music]
oh
there's a granite is in place
and solids
sell it as
solid
yep
wow look at that damn man like butter
oh nice the only thing that's missing
this is not actually meant to be there
like a walk-in door
so there's no handle on the outside
there's only one on the inside
but yeah we're gonna have to be a little
bit creative but I'm sure we will find a
solution
we got this old oven that we were
storing for a while already in the white
tent and since we want to install it
this week it's now time to take it down
to the ruin and clean it up
[Applause]
[Music]
turn it 90.
[Music]
so this oven has clearly not been used
in a long time lots of rust lots of dirt
let's see if I can get it nice and shiny
again
[Music]
one piece
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and we also need
half a meter a half a meter extra pipe
to get above the roof Ridge
yeah
[Music]
thank you
nice boards
they're already quite finished
throwing and groove all around
nice Pinewood
they said it was a
Portuguese
Casa Madera the size of this
tag of wood it's a lot
all right
we're ready for the next step Tasman I'm
ready Frank's gone Frank's gone see you
Frank
um but we will we will manage this
we're going to screw these wooden boards
onto our wall framing normally you would
put a vapor barrier there we think that
we don't need it because of the rest of
our wall construction so we have the
brick wall and then we have space
between the brick and the wood
and in between the wood there's our
insulation and what would happen is that
the moist from inside from breathing and
cooking goes through the insulation and
condensates on the brick wall
and the bricks we feel will suck up the
water and when it's a sunny day they dry
out from the outside
we're going to leave the bathroom
unfinished for the seasons for this
winter
so we can still see inside there uh what
happens on the bricks and the wood how
it behaves and we're gonna go one half
unoiled and one half oiled to see the
difference in the weathering
try this and see the outcome
let's go
so we're putting in the first board
um we're we're having it off the ground
because the ground is really not level
we're leveling out the first layer and
then later we mount one that fits
underneath
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
uh 153 huh 153 all right
[Music]
whoa too long
too long yeah that's too long it's one
mil one I need a bit of space there
around the left
[Music]
[Music]
what's that for lucky to keep the screws
we put in in a nice straight line
whoa whoa whoa wait normally you would
put these boards in place with attacker
nailing them to the wall frame but we
are using screws because we want to be
able to reuse our materials to make this
easier we have a nice screw system that
Dave will explain you all right so let's
talk about our screw system and the main
reason for setting it up is that we just
want to make sure we can reuse our
screws more and realistically because
compared to a nail which is very hard to
reuse Advance if you take it out
probably Rusty a screw is pretty easy in
reusing you can drill it take it out and
reuse it again and it's kind of a very
unique property about screws but
realistically in real life this hardly
happens because once you take something
apart you should then sort out the
screws you have and probably you have a
lot of different options different
lengths different sizes so most of the
time all the screws unlocked in this
bucket with a very mixed sizes and then
you don't really want to sort them out
or you don't really want to use them
and this actually is caused by a few
problems which is lying within the
complexity of all the screws you use
so on the one hand you have a lot of
different screw heads so you have
Phillips flat torque hexagon Square so
that's a lot of diversity in different
screw types but then even within let's
say torque you would have different
sizes 15 10 20 25 then you also have a
lot of different finishes so you could
have stainless you could have normal
steel you could have coated zinc
galvanized so many diversity in there as
well
then you also have different types of
Crews here a full threat or half tread
and which also requires another
separation
and then you just have all the different
lengths from 10 16 20 25 30 30 35 so it
just adds up so this just means you have
a lot of variables and quite easily a
very complex crew system so here we have
our current crew system it's a lot of
small little boxes that contain screws
the screws inside is a bit of a mix of
different projects throughout the years
screws bought in different stores so we
have a lot of Phillips a lot of torque
many different lengths many different
thicknesses different hat sizes so since
we're building here things and are going
to build a lot of things in a community
setting we really want to make sure the
system is built and set up in a way that
if a person comes they takes something
apart they can easily find which crew
belongs to which box because the boxing
system is cool but we just have too much
diversity so we spend a lot of time
trying to nail down the most essential
screws we need so we started research
topic online where you can see and we
asked you guys for some feedback back
and now let me show you the result of
that because the screws arrived
so here we have it 100 kilogram of
screws but let me unbox them so now you
can see what makes it so different
[Music]
foreign
let me explain a few things what makes
this our system one hand is reduced
reduced a lot of sizes so these are all
the sizes we have so we have big steps
in between for instance we go from 80 to
60 to 40 so we don't have the in between
sizes so we just have to stick with
these
and then we've set on torque only torque
and three different head sizes this one
is torque 10 or 20. the blue one and the
green one 30.
um
and then it's from two different brands
so this is the same brand this is the
same brand
and the reason for doing that is that
let's say you're done working you have
this crew that uh visually it's quite
different than the ones next to it
because it's a different brand so you
can quite easily recognize that it
should be in this box because it's way
too big for here and way too small for
here so it's another way to just make
visual identification easy
um
because yeah as you can see they look
quite different from these ones
then the two Brands they're just two
brands that we found around here I guess
it doesn't really matter which brand and
just make sure yeah pick one that you
still feel is around in a few years so
you can reorder all your screws
and we actually also have these ones
which feels a bit outside of the screw
system but somewhat in is the hex Crush
which you sometimes use for bigger
constructions those are a few different
sizes there we probably use them way
less but they're also part of the screw
system
so now it's a matter of us to make sure
we stick with all these sizes really
Incorporated in our drawings that we
only go for these sizes and adjust our
designs to it and then hopefully start
using these as much as possible and when
we're done with it uh taking down the
building so we can bring them back so
now I did go there in the screw system
and we can start screwing
[Music]
thank you
I'm actually gonna be the utility place
there's gonna be a boiler over here
so we're gonna have to go through the
wall here and also in the top
for our ventilation and pipe of the
boiler We're Gonna Leave This open for
now and then uh flexible
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so this wall is the curved wall of our
house
and um
we made two straight walls on the inside
but they are not in the same angle so
that means that they would meet
somewhere here
then we put this solid wood strip
which I'm now gonna work up onto with my
boards in this corner there's gonna be
the kitchen so we're gonna use the oil
ports in there
[Music]
foreign
yeah yeah otherwise you get in trouble
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right guys
[Applause]
that's been some really hard work but it
starts to look like a proper house now
we have used 65 square meters of wooden
boards and about 1500 screws quite a lot
we are happy with the results we've got
some nice experimental stuff in there
like our wall system without a vapor
barrier and oiling half of the wall
boards besides that it just looks really
good
if you want to know more about the
materials or the designs that we've used
you can visit our research module and
join the discussion
in the next video we are going to start
wrapping up the camp for the winter
season that will arrive soon
different tasks around and some really
good waterfall stuff
thanks for watching and see you in the
next update
don't forget to subscribe people
[Music]
whoa
where videos please support us on
patreon yeah you can even watch next
week's video right now and even without
ads you